bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono poi pj oggi
siamo sull'ultimo episodio di blair
witch quindi spero che vi piaccia
buona visione ma che è successo niente
lo porto io a questo successo ha
mangiato troppo avanti ma non è successo
niente ragazzi cosa sta succendo che
secondario avevo appoggiato progetti a
terra sono sicuro si dai non succede
niente spero ma come abbandonarlo
allora lei abbandonare aventino di un
attimo aspetta un attimo non l'ho
abbandonato le scene a dire staples
io non abbandonerei mai il mio cane se
non mi rispunta vi ammazzo governo
pronti sceriffo ma è morto è ancora vivo
ma cos'è successo
no ragazzi datemi il cane subito mi
ammazzo di atri e sono svenuto ho letto
mi spiegate cosa sta succedendo devo
fare io
ma basta non vedo niente televisioni
continuano a roma inguardabile del
successo messaggio però andò segnale
assente va bene vado nei messaggi
vodafone servizio gratuito basta
guarda su cagato addosso è una boxe
fight
ma come è lei la strega cos'è a
continuare a riprendere sta roba
si scava contronti mt se io mi avvicino
lei scompare come una pasqua in famiglia
non vedo
non era una posta c'è praticamente la e
una parte completamente mai infatti del
gioco questa dove il mio cane
maledizione cioè la cassetta va bene
guardiamola sono io col mio cane questo
successo qualcuno ci ha ripresi sono io
che guardo
qualcuno ha ripreso le cose poi se io
guardo la videocamera non dovrebbe
tornare il cane ma sempre funzionato a
videocamera no chiesto se venendo
fortissimo spiegami figurati sono
cascato nell'acqua mamma mia e sta
facendo impazzire strano lo faccio io
[Musica]
si spera
però poi dirlo anche in modo più gentile
però va beh no limits
come tu sei morto come è morto ti prego
fatemi di spuntare il cane mi supplico
vi supplico sul sito mi subito non può
avermi ammazzato il cane dai veramente
no non lo accetta stato non l'accetto
propria star vi ammazzo in tutto questo
il bambino è qua e qua dentro stesso sia
entra in trance veloce metti la torcia
una sega apri apri a porta
no che è successo tutto sei un genio
io avevo visto blair witch 2 3 anni fa
il finale era proprio dentro questa casa
cui cioè non vorrei che non accada
tamagni barghetti nave fosse per questo
quindi non vorrei che forse siamo il
finale però il quale mi deve scontare
ragazzi non me ne frega niente
ci siamo ragazzi sto per aprire la porta
del basement eccola si è aperto
ragazzino bimbo minchia non ho mai visto
cosa c'é qua sotto neanche nel film si
vede piano di sopra il nuovo
minchia che kakà questo mi sono spiegato
di sotto chi ha questo era fatto
benissimo
porca vacca che jobs che non raga
pazzesco questo non me l'aspettavo mai
però fosse dietro
no no no no vabbè mi chiami ammazzo
bruttissimo
no ragazzi mai vista una roba così
questo l'ha studiato benissimo con jump
square park caputa ecco la pace e meno
male direi meno male che non si smuove
di un giro di prove davantino che pieno
sprechiamo l'acqua così come se niente
fosse vabbè se ci sono insomma aspetta
prima io stavo parlando con me stesso
no ero io che parlavo quindi quando mi
diceva delle luci io stavo dicendo a me
stesso di accendere luci minchia ma che
tra una pazzesca quindi ero io che
parlavo con me stesso e la sceriffo a io
l'ho fatto fortezza da ma non ci credo
ma alla fine sono stato io sempre a fare
tutto un casino
no ecco che questo no
come ti immagini il tuo futuro nord
morente secondo me se mi accoglie vado a
sinistra non bolancio facciamo che non
mi affaccio porca vacca siamo non lo so
ma credo che stia prendendo il controllo
del mio corpo non sono proprio sicuro ma
ce l'abbiamo fatta
ma dai e meno male perché ero abbastanza
piccola la casa quindi ci ha messo un po
a trovare il seminterrato vedrà il
bambino nella madonna
eccolo
ci vuole la chiave pure
bellavista velo ok è vero
quindi veramente siamo due ci veniamo
basta che il bambino si saldi voi è il
mio cane se qualcuno vuole evitare
non ci passo c'è più o meno strisciando
ci passo che offre che schifo chi è che
ha scavato sta roba punto di domanda
eccolo eccolo
ma adesso sfonderà la porta io piccolo
soldato riscat rischio
chris lewis vice pres presentazione a
l'hai uccisa per questo motivo
l'hai uccisa perché se l'avrebbe fa
scorrere insomma
[Musica]
buono spirito è più facile vedere
quindi alla fine io divento lunghi lo
sapevo lo sapevo
si capiva già da un po però minchia
quindi adesso mi controllo la strega
perché io sono stato no bull se ne va
perché no io ero non ho capito
minchia un casino io ero lui nell'ice
sia resa dalla rabbia de sparito il
ciclo continua carver è rinato
nonostante free the bullet è riuscito a
sopravvivere good ending va bene io ero
lui ero carver ero io lui perché una
certo vi è spuntato testata tutti i
particolari non ha detto una parola
praticamente io sono diventato lui
minchia peter e va beh
non avevo capito starò qui inizia un
combattuto contro me stesso
dai figata mi è piaciuto non pensavo non
pensavo mario girare così intricatissimo
però ci stava bello strano ma bello
questo l'ho capito io a posto feste rave
airways ragazzi sono diventato il nemico
perché ho fatto cose cattive nella mia
vita spero che vi sia piaciuto lasciando
un bel commento mi piace fatemi sapere
cosa ne pensate voi nel finale io alla
fine alla fine si è spiegato tutto però
c'è mi immaginavo fosse intricata la
trama invece no
cioè tipo di intricata di buyout lassù
secondo me pochi jumps che era avuto in
questi episodi ma ben fatti cioè quei
pochi che c'erano mammamia valevano
tutto quindi è veramente splendido figo
per me ci sta ci vediamo in una prossima
serie horror questo era blazwick
iscrivetevi al canale 600 la
campanellina se volete che derivino
notifiche sono di video e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
ragazzi un po su un episodio deve
contemplare il muro per un paio di ore
dopo questo finale però il cane vivo
quindi a posto beh ragazzi
[Musica]